was nun herr steinmeier was nun herr
bundespräsident nach ihrer wiederwahl
haben sie in der bundesversammlung heute
eine sagen wir mal sehr entschlossene
rede gehalten vor allem in richtung
putin bevor wir die lage in über die
lage in europa sprechen wie die
krebsgefahr vielleicht eine kurze frage
zu ihrem stil heute werden sie in ihrer
zweiten amtszeit jetzt ein
bundespräsident der klare ansagen macht
klare ansagen ganz sicher man kann sie
nicht jeden tag machen man muss darauf
achten dass man gehört wird deshalb habe
ich immer sehr darauf geachtet dass ich
als bundespräsident nicht als der
tägliche besserwisser wahrgenommen werde
sondern in solche situationen dann
hinein gehen wenn ich den eindruck habe
der bundespräsident wird gehört heute
ist es nichts besonderes bei der wahl
des bundespräsidenten und der
anstehenden rede haben viele hingehört
aber auch in der vergangenheit habe ich
versucht
situationen zu finden bei denen ich den
eindruck habe da gibt es ein wirkliches
bedürfnis entweder nach orientierung
oder aber auch nach trauer und trost in
der trauer und es ist
es ist die definition des richtigen
zeitpunkts und
es ist die orientierung auf die eigene
glaubwürdigkeit die man auch braucht um
in krisen wie im november 2017 dann
neuwahlen zu verhindern und der noch zu
versuchen eine regierung zustande zu
sagen heute die kraft der demokratie
beschworen in dieser rede auch neben
russland darüber reden wir gleich wäre
es nicht besser gewesen wenn sie über
die kraft der demokratie sprechen wenn
sie heute wirklich einen gegenkandidaten
gehabt hätten eine herausforderin von
den grünen oder einen klaren
konservativen wäre das nicht an
demokratischere signal gewesen das ist
jetzt nicht sehr freundlich gegenüber
den gegenkandidaten die es gab einer
gegenkandidatin und zwei gegenkandidaten
bei denen ich mich auch ausdrücklich
dafür bedankt habe dass sie den mut
gehabt haben zu kandidieren in einer
situation bei der vielleicht der eigene
sieg nicht besonders wahrscheinlich war
das braucht demokratie demokratie
braucht alternativen aber um auf den
kern ihrer frage zu kommen ich glaube
das ist der vielleicht auch etwas
besonderes in der politischen kultur
dieses landes und darüber sollten wir
uns freuen dass es immer wieder
möglichkeiten immer wieder gelegenheiten
gibt wo sich entscheidungen nicht längst
von parteigrenzen und auch nicht eine
logik von regierungen an einer logik von
regierung und opposition orientieren
sondern wo kleine und große parteien
zusammenkommen um gemeinsam etwas auf
den weg zu bringen was für diese
demokratie förderlich ist und insofern
hat die bundestagspräsidentin heute
vielleicht nicht ganz zu unrecht gesagt
die bundesversammlung ist immer auch ein
hochamt der demokratie und viele haben
es heute so empfunden sie haben heute
ihre wiederwahl auch genutzt die erste
rede um ganz klare botschaften richtung
moskau zu senden lösen sie die schlinge
ich glaube so war der satz an putin
lösen sie die schlinge um den hals der
ukraine jetzt reißt der bundeskanzler
morgen nach kräften dienstag nach moskau
die amerikaner sprechen von einem
bevorstehenden angriff womöglich
mittwoch ist es sogar terminiert wie
hoch schätzen sie heute die kriegsgefahr
ich kann das nicht einschätzen ich kann
auch nur von gefahren reden weil ich
nicht weiß auf welchen informationen auf
welchen elementen die andere das
amerikanische wissen beruht dass es
möglicherweise mittwoch zu einer
invasion kommen könnte ich hoffe dass
das abzuwenden ist und deshalb bin ich
den hauptstädten bin ich paris
washington berlin sehr sehr dankbar für
alle bemühungen die in diesen tagen
unternommen werden ich glaube dass
washington natürlich für die für die
russen film oscar der wichtigste
gesprächspartner ist wenn es um fragen
von rüstung und abrüstung militärischer
präsenz in osteuropa geht aber wir
sollten auch nicht unterschätzen dass
deutschland gemeinsam mit frankreich
etwas einzubringen hat in diesem prozess
in einem prozess der hoffentlich krieg
verhindert die präsenz die präsenz und
das engagement im normandie format ist
nicht unwichtig denn wir haben hier
einen gesprächs rahmen ein
gesprächsformat an dem beide seiten
sowohl die ukraine wie russland an
interesse haben und solange das der fall
ist lohnt es sich da zu investieren das
tut die deutschen fährt so ein bisschen
fest im moment hat man den eindruck sie
selbst fliegen ja am dienstag nach
lettland also ins beide kommen auf die
baltischen staaten darauf weisen sie hin
fühlen sich durch russland ja bedroht
gerade auch nach der rede heute hatte
man so ein wenig das gefühl könnten auch
sie eine vermittlerrolle spielen würden
sie eine solche überhaupt annehmen nein
eine vermittlerrolle steht nicht an die
bundesregierung das habe ich eben gesagt
tut das was möglich ist die
außenministerin der bundeskanzler auch
in eigener person und insofern gibt es
jetzt gar keinen grund dazwischen zu
funken aber da wir wissen dass die
bedrohung sich nicht nur auf die ukraine
auswirke ich hatte gerade den
litauischen präsidentin zu gast den mir
auch nochmal geschildert hat wie die
stimmung im eigenen land ist weil ich
nach lettland eingeladen bin nun dort zu
reden kann ich natürlich ergänzend hilfe
leisten um zu versichern dass
deutschland sich seiner verantwortung
in der nato gegenüber den
bündnispartnern bewusst ist und dass
diese sich darauf verlassen genau daran
gibt es ja durchaus zweifel in manchen
staaten in ost- und mitteleuropa es gab
auch zweifel in den usa bis zu diesem
besuch von olaf scholz sie haben ja im
vergangenen september vor der uno
beteuert deutschland bleibe auch nach
der ära merkel ein verlässlicher partner
das ist in den usa aber anderswo doch
zweifel gab und vielleicht immer noch
zweifel gibt die sehr besorgt sieht ist
ich weiß nicht ob es diese zweifel
wirklich gibt ich nehme jetzt dafür
meine für meinen befund das was wir nach
den gesprächen zwischen bundeskanzler
scholz und präsident biden aus den usa
gehört haben in dem gespräch ist
sichergestellt worden dass man sich auf
einen gemeinsamen weg
befindet und begibt sollte es zu einem
militärischen invasion in die ukraine
kommen und insofern habe ich nicht den
eindruck dass bei dem engsten
transatlantischen bündnis partner
jedenfalls in der administration ganz
schaffte bedenken oder zweifel bestehen
und sie sollten auch nicht in der
ukraine bestehen ich habe zuletzt den
bubble jahr in erinnerung an das
massaker vor 80 jahren unsere
verantwortung für die ukraine betont
alle erinnern sich daran dass
deutschland behilflich war als im
februar 2014 das morden auf dem majdan
stattfand und wir uns mit polen und mit
frankreich bemüht haben das zu ende zu
bringen bundeskanzlerin merkel ist
mehrfach ich durfte sie begleiten in
minsk unterwegs gewesen um aus dem
konflikt in der ost ukraine kein
flächenbrand in der ganzen ukraine oder
ganz europa werden zu lassen deutschland
hat viel wirtschaftlicher hilfe
geleistet seit 2014 insofern sollten wir
unser licht auch nicht so sehr unter den
scheffel stellen wir haben unsere
verantwortung gezeigt in der
vergangenheit und sie wird jetzt gezeigt
in dem die deutsche regierung bemühungen
unternimmt um einen konflikt vor dem
viele eine angst haben auch wir um
diesen konflikt nicht zum ausbruch
kommen zu lassen das militärische
verhindert wird betonen die
verbundenheit mit der ukraine
wie schwierig ist bei der bewertung
vielleicht auch an der deutschen rolle
in dem zusammenhang dass es dann einen
sozialdemokratischen ex- kanzler gibt er
beim pipeline projekt nord stream zwei
engagiert ist in der russischen gas
industrie wichtige posten hat ist dieses
engagement schröders privatsache oder
macht ihm jemand vielleicht auch sie
deutlich dass es deutschland schneidet
sie haben den bundespräsidenten
eingeladen ich habe heute in meiner rede
klar stellung bezogen zu dem was ich
zudem keine konflikt gegenwärtig sagen
kann ich habe klar benannt wo die
verantwortung für die gegenwärtige
bedrohung für den drohenden konflikt ist
habe unsere verantwortung gegenüber der
ukraine und gegenüber den baltischen
staaten betont ich glaube deutlicher
kann man es nicht sagen ohne dass sich
hat zu dem ergebnis komme dass wir
dem schicksal sozusagen schon ergeben
sind ganz im gegenteil diplomatische
bemühungen sind nicht umsonst sie
sollten so stark wie möglich
ausgefahren werden
aber man sollte schröder nicht so ernst
nehmen ist dass die regierung
entscheidet nach anderen maßstäben das
ist ja gegenwärtig sichtbar und deshalb
glaube ich wird bei unseren partnern in
europa auch transatlantisch und
verstanden dass die deutsche politik die
deutsche außenpolitik das deutsche
handeln in diesem konflikt
von der deutschen regierung bestimmt
wird und das ganze auch scholz bezieht
sich immer wieder auf die ostpolitik
damals mit willy brandt ging es um ein
neues gleichgewicht der supermächte um
mehr spielraum für deutschland um wandel
durch handel in der sowjetunion und
mitte sowjetunion ist ostpolitik heute
angesichts dieser revisionistischen
rolle moskaus die moskau will ja die
grenzen in europa infrage stellen
möglicherweise ändern die richtige
strategie
so kann man glaube ich die frage gar
nicht beantworten es ist die
verantwortung von regierungen erhalten
geblieben für frieden in europa zu
sorgen es nicht erneut zu militärischen
konfrontation kommen zu lassen ich habe
heute nicht umsonst in meiner rede ganz
am ende zu der ruß und keine passage
daran erinnert dass in knapp drei jahren
450 jahre unterzeichnung der schlussakte
in helsinki begehen werden und es sollte
aus meiner sicht nicht der tag sein an
dem bescheid das scheitern aller
bemühungen bekennen deshalb es lohnt
sich zu investieren in alle bemühungen
seien sie noch so klein und ich hoffe
dass es den hauptstädten gelingt unter
hilfe der deutschen bundesregierung
gelingt das was viele befürchten zu
vermeiden und russland auf einen weg zu
bringen der signale der deeskalation
sendet bevor man in weitergehende
gespräche eintritt ihr vorgänger joachim
gauck hat glaube ich 2014 bei der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz von einer
sicherheitspolitischen verweigerung
deutschlands gesprochen muss ihrer
ansicht nach deutschland einen
glaubwürdigen beitrag auch zur
militärischen abschreckung russlands
leisten sie haben das wort abschreckung
heute einmal selbst in den mund genommen
ja ich habe meine letzte rede auf der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz an dem ich
mir noch erinnere auch
dazu genutzt um zu sagen
dass wir wahrnehmen müssen dass die usa
sich auf einen ostasiatischen partner
konzentrieren
politisch aber möglicherweise auch
militärisch mehr in dieses verhältnis
investieren dass das zur folge hat dass
wir die europäische säule in der nato
stärken müssen und wenn wir die über die
europäisch so soll es stärken reden dann
heißt das natürlich auch ein stärkeres
engagement von deutscher seite in dieser
europäischen säule der nato herr
bundespräsident zu dieser sendung gehört
die satz ergänzung sie kennen das wir
geben einen halbsatz vor und sie
ergänzen ihn bitte möglichst kurz und
der erste halbsatz lautet wenn olaf
scholz jetzt für die ampel regierung
sozusagen als motto aufruft mehr
fortschritt wagen wird dort das für mich
dass ich fortschritt unterstütze
fortschritt ist den vielen bereichen
möglich und nötig im augenblick bezieht
er sich weitgehend auf die maßnahmen im
kampf gegen den klimawandel und das habe
ich heute als die überlebensfrage der
menschheit
definiert das ist mit steinmeier stolz
und bars in wichtigen verfassungs ämtern
jetzt eine sozialdemokratische
renaissance gibt
erstens
die parteimitgliedschaft des
bundespräsidenten ruth meine sowie die
aller meiner vorgänger ansonsten glaube
ich treffen sie auf ähnliche
konstellationen
mit
familienzugehörigkeit union zu früheren
zeiten auch also so besonders ist die
situation jetzt nicht thema klima sie
haben es angesprochen für die ökobilanz
des bundespräsidenten innerdeutsche
reisen künftig nur noch mit dem zug zu
machen nur noch mit dem zug weiß ich
nicht aber wir haben das relativ häufig
genutzt wir haben sogar vor einem jahr
die erste auslandsreise mit dem zug
gemacht nach tschechien war wunderschön
dass meine frau elke büdenbender jetzt
wieder in ihr richter amt zurückkehrt
unterstütze ich
sie hat es entschieden wie ich finde mit
sehr sehr nachvollziehbaren gründen vor
fünf jahren bei der weg aus dem
richterzimmer in die öffentlichkeit ein
sehr weiter weg sie musste sich
einfinden in eine rolle die es gar nicht
gibt die der first lady jetzt ist nicht
mehr alles neu und ich verstehe nicht
nur dass sie einen teil ihrer
arbeitszeit dem erlernten und geliebten
beruf widmet sondern unterstütze das
dass ich als bundespräsident bürgerinnen
und bürgern schon an ostern wieder die
hände schütteln darf das hoffe ich auch
thema corona die bundesregierung hat die
impfpflicht herr bundespräsident zur
gewissensfrage erklärt von
parteipolitischen mehrheiten abgelöst
sie sind ja auch so eine art wächter
über parlamentarische politische
verfahren hätte man von der neuen
regierung nicht erwarten müssen dass sie
sich in so einer wichtigen frage auf
einen gemeinsamen gesetzentwurf einig
das kann man erwarten aber wenn man an
beispiele aus früheren zeiten
präimplantationsdiagnostik
denkt oder überarbeitung des
transplantationsgesetzes
solchen
gesetzgebungsverfahren in denen
gewissensfragen eine große rolle
spielten fraktionsdisziplin nicht kalt
ist es häufiger so gewesen dass in der
tat die gesetzesinitiative aus den
parlamenten heraus ergriffen wurde ich
denke diesem beispiel
folgt das was wir im augenblick sehen
mein satz den ich immer wieder hole im
augenblick im pflicht des vor allen
dingen debatten pflicht und ich sehe
dass die genutzt wird
stichwort impfpflicht jetzt sind gut
drei viertel der deutschen zweimal
geimpft 55 prozent gebucht hat alle
aufrufe haben am ende nicht wirklich
genutzt auch ihre offenkundig nicht sie
waren ja da vehement dabei hat das auch
etwas mit dem mangel an geschlossenheit
in der ampelkoalition zu tun
kann ich ihnen nicht sagen zunächst mal
versuche ich ja immer wieder darauf
hinzuweisen dass die ganz große mehrheit
sich vernünftig verantwortlich
solidarisch verhalten hat und mehr als
80 prozent denke ich jetzt inzwischen
auch geburtstag zweimal geimpft sind
zweimal geimpft sind insofern glaube ich
müssen wir erstmal danke denjenigen
sagen die sich so verhalten haben die
überzeugungsarbeit gegenüber den fertig
verbliebenen 20 prozent war nicht
erfolgreich genug muss fortgesetzt
werden und ich hoffe dass wir nicht am
ende einer entwicklung stehen sondern
dass wir uns in den prozentanteilen
derjenigen die sich impfen lassen ein
bisschen nach vorne gerannt kochen hat
als lern frage braucht die impfpflicht
jetzt überhaupt ne na.de bezieht sich ja
jetzt gar nicht so sehr auf die auf die
aktuelle quote
der geimpften bzw ungeimpften sondern
bezieht sich auf das risiko einer neuen
variante die möglicherweise im herbst
kommen könnte ich bin kein mediziner ich
bin kein wissenschaftler ich kann das
nicht beurteilen
wenn das risiko groß ist
gibt es jedenfalls anlass über die
impfpflicht zu diskutieren wenn sie
sehen dass corona spaziergänge von
rechtsextremen unterwandert werden dass
hass und hetze im netz zu nehmen das
sogar auf gage von privathäusern vor
privathäusern von politikern stattfinden
glauben sie und das haben sie ja
intensiv praktiziert in dieser corona
krise noch an das konzept des dialogs
mit den endgegnern oder ist das
angesichts dieser radikalisierung nicht
gespeichert wer für mich immer eine eine
rote linie gezogen bei im skeptikern
selbst bei impfgegnern habe ich immer
noch gesagt wenn das eine linie ist bei
der ich weiß positiv weiß dass sie sich
hass und gewalt nicht verschrieben haben
schließlich gespräche nicht aus man
gewinnt nicht jeden zurück aber man kann
der bewegung das argument nehmen das
staat ihnen nicht zuhört dass sie
ausgeschlossen werden dass
demokratie und demokratische grundregeln
ihnen gegenüber nicht beachtet werden
insofern glaube ich nutzt es schon immer
wieder versuche zu machen auch auf
skeptiker zuzugehen
ich glaube wir haben am ende auch keine
alternative weil
jeder der sich von der demokratie
abwendet fehlt auch im zweiten schritt
der demokratie und
wir sollten die fehlerquote so gering
wie möglich sie haben ja zuletzt bei
einem ihrer bürgerforen in schloss
bellevue erlebt wie eine impf gegnerin
mit schwer überprüfbaren argumenten aber
mit viel emotion sozusagen das gespräch
dominierte bei allem bemühen auch
kritischen stimmen einen raum zu geben
sie haben ja eben nochmal begründet
warum sie das tun müssen sie nicht
künftig deutlicher machen was im
demokratischen diskurs geht und was eben
auch nicht mehr das ist ja eines von
vielen gesprächen gewesen und es war
noch nicht nur einmal im skeptiker dabei
auch die sind unterschiedlich und nicht
jeder beruft sich auf kryptische
forschungsergebnisse von universitäten
die ich noch nicht gehört habe da ist
auch jede gesprächssituation anders und
die frage ist nur hat man den mut sich
darauf einzulassen scheut man die
kontroverse oder versucht eben auch in
solchen gesprächen immer wieder ein
beispiel dafür zu geben viel mehr kann
ich ja gar nicht so gar nicht tun als
dass die auseinandersetzung tatsächlich
auch gesucht wird auch mit den
skeptikern gesucht wird möglicherweise
sogar hingegen gibt es auch eine grenze
physik wo sie sagen jetzt hat es keinen
sinn eindeutig wenn wenn wir sehen
dass das menschen sind die sich in den
sozialen medien oder gar schlimmer mit
formen von hass und gewalt
beschäftigt haben oder zum ausdruck
gebracht haben dann ist für mich die
rote linie die ich heute in der rede
gezogen habe erreicht am 18 märz endet
ihre bisherige amtszeit am 19 beginnt
die zweite wenn sie jetzt für die
nächsten fünf jahre wird bis 20 27 geht
es ja eine überschrift zu einer art
motto formulieren müssten kurz und knapp
wie würde das lauten
ich würde das motto ableiten aus
dem ende meiner rede was ich wie ich
heute gehalten habe und würde daran
erinnern dass demokratie ein versprechen
und eine erwartung zugleich ist ich
würde gerne eine haltung in der
deutschen bevölkerung
etablieren helfen die regierungen und
demokratie und demokratische
institutionen ich als etwas fremdes
sehen was einem gegenüber steht sondern
auch die menschen aktivieren
überzeugen dass man in einer demokratie
selbst womöglich verantwortung
übernehmen muss das müssen nicht
unbedingt im engeren sinne politische
ämter seinen daumen hab ich gesagt jeder
der denkt als nur an sich selbst jeder
der im gemeinderat oder im verein etwas
tut für die gemeinschaft der ist schon
eine stärkung der demokratie zur
verantwortung ermutigen vielen dank herr
bundespräsident dass ich dann was nun
übrigens nach zweig plus regeln vielen
dank liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
für ihr interesse schön sonntagabend
noch es aus berlin
[Musik]